emmy award-winning actor peter scolari
died on friday morning following a
two-year battle with cancer he was 66
years old just act natural
what is that supposed to mean
you're so cranky
just watch me work
the actor got his first big break on the
1980 tv comedy bosom buddies he starred
as henry desmond hildegard alongside tom
hanks on boys and buddies we we had one
uh
steadfast rule and that was if
if one of us didn't know what to do just
look at the other guy see we'd always
had that scolari went on to have a
career that spanned over four decades i
need to thank lena dunham and landed an
emmy for his work on hbo's girls where
he starred as the father of lena
dunham's character anna you're very
funny girl thank you papa dunham paid
tribute to her co-star on friday posting
this pic to instagram alongside a
caption that read in part quote the
shyest extrovert the most dramatic
comedian the most humble icon you had
lived enough life to know that a tv show
was just a tv show but also to
appreciate just what it meant to be
allowed to play pretend for a living and
you never let us forget that this job
was a privilege
i feel very lucky most recently scolari
portrayed bishop thomas marks on cbs's
supernatural drama evil his resume
includes work on both tv and film
including fosse verdin madoff the good
fight murphy brown the west wing er
gotham law order svu ally mcbeal from
the earth to the moon honey i shrunk the
kids the tv show the polar express and
many many more but scolari's success
wasn't limited to the big and small
screen he also appeared on broadway in
hits like hairspray wicked sly fox magic
bird bronx bombers and the true and
lucky guy which hanks was also a part of
scolari is survived by his wife tracy
shane whom he married in 2013
and his children nicholas joseph keaton
and callie